you can travel a Multiverse
yet again we've been given new footage
from another leaks TV spot for Doctor
Strange and a Multiverse of Madness so
let's break it down so the trailer
begins with Doctor Strange America
Chavez and Wong having lunch together
Doctor Strange then tells America Chavez
so you can travel a Multiverse in which
Chavez responds with yep and then Doctor
Strange asking her to prove it we then
have a quick shot of America Chavez
attempting to break out of a prison cell
before it transitions into a shot of her
star-shaped portal who then see doctor
strange and America Chavez fallen out of
the star-shaped portal until they come
out of another portal and land onto the
ground all this is new footage here and
everything is looking really good we've
seen these star-shaped portals in
previous TV spots but we actually
haven't seen them in action yet so it's
cool to see America Chavez using them
now we then have a new shot of America
Chavez and Defender strange traversing
in this mysterious looking environment
and what I think they're trying to get
is this object in the background which I
think is the book of Ashanti then we
have new footage of Doctor Strange split
in the bus in half and has been thrown
at him by garganos the way everything is
shot here is really really beautiful and
I cannot wait to see what Sam Romi has
in store for us for this film so if you
guys did enjoy this breakdown of the new
leaked footage we have seen please leave
a like And subscribe to show your
support thanks for watching guys